art parce qu'on va aborder un sujet
difficile un sujet douloureux qui arrive
en novembre
on parle de suicide mais surtout on
parle de prévention du suicide
on parle d'espoir surtout avec que notre
invité alors aujourd'hui une invitée
elle est à québec c'est madame michèle
audette madame odette bonjour bonjour à
vous un manic madame odette vous êtes
commissaire à l'aide fatale enquête
nationale sur les femmes et les filles
autochtones est assassiné aujourd'hui
nous n'allons pas parler de leurs fans
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de vous
parce que vous êtes une survivante du
suicide en fait vous avez vous lu un
jour disparaître alors on vend on va en
parler et on va aussi parler évidemment
de ce qui donne l'espoir donc
d'initiatives diverses qui ont lieu un
peu partout au canada dans les
communautés avec shark boy personnes
bonjour en jeu et puis avec mathis
harvey bonjour matisse alors avec mathis
on va aller évidemment au nunavik 1 voir
ce qui se passe dans cette partie du
pays qui a été drôlement ébranlé au
cours des dernières semaines dernières
semaines tout à fait pop tard que la
semaine dernière oui mais en fait je dis
au cours des dernières semaines mais en
réalité s'est depuis développé les
années oui celle-là on en parle beaucoup
plus depuis les dernières semaines on
est c'est vrai et puis avec vos chars
évidemment l'art l'art qui vient sauver
des vies qui vient donner cette envie
d'aller plus loin de vivre de voir le
soleil exactement le sentiment
d'appartenance être entouré d'êtres
d'être senti qu'on est accompagné dans
ses pôles dans ce domaine donc autant
cacher des jeunes et les actifs
absolument
alors on va y revenir mais d'abord
michèle audette racontez nous qu'est ce
qui vous a amené un jour à vouloir vous
enlever la vie s'est il y avait
plusieurs événements je vous dirais du
moment de ma naissance jusqu'à jusqu'en
2013 où on subit on nous impose
on nous force où on nous surprend avec
soin
comment était mon mode de vie à l'époque
que ce soit la communauté ou une
agression sexuelle une violence latéral
le divorce de mes parents la
consommation toxicomanie donc c'est
plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs événements
qui fait que ça devienne couche une peau
comme un oignon le de maisons plus lourd
à porter et 2013 va avoir été
extrêmement difficile où un comme
superwomen à cette époque là c'est ce
que je pensais que je t'aime tellement
j'étais dans l'esprit du rova planète
avec le mouvement des femmes de ville
harcèlement au travail de vivre une
séparation sa ramener tous ces monstres
là où ces couches et un moment donné
la dernière action pour moi et souffler
puis capable de respirer plus capable de
vivre le suicide était
la porte de 0,10 exactement merci la vie
je suis contente aujourd'hui d'être
vivante et je retournerai plus lol alors
je le disais on en parle parce que cette
semaine c'est la conférence dialogue
pour la vie 2018 et justement le thème
c'est favoriser une vie d'espoir avec et
pour nos enfants et nos jeunes parce que
c'est vrai que souvent c'est à
l'adolescence il ya tellement de
changements dans nos vies les
traumatismes qu'on peut avoir vécu plus
jeunes remontent à la surface et on est
conscient à ce moment là en fait est ce
qu'on l'ait conscient du geste qu'on
voudrait poser
on réfléchit on le rejette moite que
c'était comme ça
j'allais pas chercher de l'aide mais je
leur ai fléchissait puis au moment où
c'était le temps de passer à l'action où
je me donnais le temps là je refusais je
me pensais mais coup sur coup et
action par dessus une eau j'étais plus
capable alors j'ai essayé toutes sortes
de manières ce matin-là le fusil une
surconsommation médicale médicaments
bruce d'autres choses et je tombe
endormi avec le fusil des mains donc ça
c'était c'était un acte du créateur ou
d'une grand mère qui me surveillent là
mais il ya un moment donné on sait même
plus moi qui avais le contrôle sur moi
alors fait que et à partir de ce moment
là j'ai j'ai accepté d'avoir cette
dépression l'a7 grand peine là d'avoir
la faiblesse ou le leu de nier que j'ai
besoin d'un oui et je me suis accrochée
au mollet physiquement du médecin à
l'hôpital en main si je ressens je veux
mourir je me connais la vie j'aime trop
la vie d'habitude donc aider moi oui est
ce que c'est une réalité particulière
chez les autochtones mais je dirais je
suis pas surprise d'entendre
mes collègues mes amis des témoignages
les gens que j'ai côtoyés dans le passé
qu'on a eu plusieurs idées noires aux
tentatives de tristement voir aussi les
statistiques très élevé chez les
autochtones depuis trop longtemps
c'est que où il ya une violence physique
émotionnel et spirituel et mentales qui
existe dans les communautés il ya
d'autres couches ou d'autres dont niveau
qui n'existe pas chez mes soeurs
québécois ce qui est une loi sur les
indiens une dépossession du territoire
la perte d'identité comme charles parle
elle a la fierté au niveau de l'identité
beaucoup de choses qui nous ont été
enlevés quand je parlais d'imposer dans
l'introduction qui font très très mal et
à cette époque love réalisé pas que ça
faisait partie de mes grandes
souffrances parlant d'identité vous avez
en plus une double identité
est ce que c'est un enjeu aussi dans
cette recherche de savoir qui on est ce
qu'on vaut oui oui très jeune quand on
accumule cette forme de viol violences
la gg huit ans
et à chaque fois que je retourne à
maliotenam donc huit ans après se disant
prêt soit 12 ans ou des adultes vont me
cracher dessus me lancer des objets me
crier après que je te voleuse de job
mais je teins enfants du togo une petite
file et par la suite c'est une violence
qui est physique en disant tu étais pas
dit si tu es pauvre et indienne
donc les blessures elle vient de tous
bords sans l'avoir demandé parce que ma
mère est tombée amoureuse plus beaux
québécois qui mon papa c'est plus tard
que à reprenant contrôle sur ma hui dans
la fin vingtaine ou là je me dis mon
dieu c'est un cadeau des inoue
québécoise
donc c'est un processus de guérison on
l'a fait en sorte que mais dans la
grande dépression 2013 les violons sont
revenus pareil pourquoi dire les violons
sont revenus à ce moment là parce que
quand convient de l'harcèlement dans un
milieu où dans une famille où on vit une
situation de violence et plusieurs
formes de violence
moi c'est pas que je pensais que j'étais
guérie j'étais guérie d'un certain passé
et que je ne faisais au dans la vérité
je faisais juste le temps c'est le
maître de communion qui prétend t la
superwoman que le mans series et en 2013
c'est là où j'ai ouvert toutes ces
portes là parce que la médecin la
docteure là que nous et on va prendre
finalement on a ouvert une toutes ces
portes là pour amener le pardon qui a
mené l'amour certains jeux proposés de
pardonner mais de dire regarde tout je
te laisse la piqûre n'ai pu me déranger
mais cela c'était font davantage fallait
le faire
oui bouchard dans votre communauté ce
que vous avez connu comme ça beaucoup de
gens qui avaient envie pour toutes
sortes de raisons de d'attenter à leur
vie
oui plusieurs mains un peu oui plusieurs
des amis j'ai perdu des amis par le
souci
et jour de l'an même jour de l'an les
choses comme ça c'est des choses qui est
qui est arrivé à plus d'une reprise
c'est des choses qui qui me sont privés
aussi c'est plusieurs plusieurs gens
plusieurs jeunes qui passent par mais
des choses comme ça je pense que c'est
très c'est malheureux ça arrive trop
souvent
alors comment changer les choses qu'est
ce qu'on doit faire dans notre société
que ce soit nous mêmes nos gouvernements
mais la société en général pour sortir
de ce cercle qui est vicieux et qui est
dangereux michel qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce que vous faites vous au
quotidien parce que vous en rencontrer
beaucoup de monde avec l' enquête
nationale vous avez rencontré énormément
de gens pour leur donner l'espoir pour
leur dire les choses vont changer
mais ce que je dis à mes propres fister
généralement plus vieux que une période
difficile où c'est la première chose
qu'on peut faire c'est pas le
gouvernement ni l'institution dans
l'immédiat mais toi comme individu oui
d'accepter cette souffrance-là cette
vulnérabilité là et regardez moi dans
les yeux quand les gens me parlent
surtout me regarde dans les yeux et on
prend ensemble contre pour la vie je
t'entends que ce soit par téléphone
messenger ou face à face et mais comme
militante ou aujourd'hui je porte la
firme avec les mocassins de militants de
commissaire au gouvernement
mais attendez vous que dans des
recommandations du rapport national et
celui du québec qui va avoir une partie
importante sur le processus de guérison
pour justement combattre le fléau le
suicide qui existe encore dans nos
communautés
ok on va les regarder ce qui se fait
d'ailleurs un petit peu partout au pays
on va passer par le nunavik d'abord
parce que la crise elle avait lieu la
récemment une crise qui a été d'ailleurs
extrêmement difficile
quels sont les principaux enjeux
dans cette crise on navigue déjà vous
avez problème entendu parler de la
réunion d'urgence qu'a eu lieu la
semaine dernière à couderc les 30 et 31
octobre ça a été un peu la honte la
sonnette d'alarmé qui a été qui a été
décrit par le chef du conseil des
commissaires rabat watts qui a convoqué
dans une lettre ouverte envoyée à des
représentants du gouvernement des
représentants hewitt une réunion
justement pour faire le point et décider
ce qu'elles ont à venir parce qu'il ya
énormément de plus en plus de suicides
qui sont recensés puis pour l'année 2010
80 ans beaucoup parler dans les médias
on peut pas qu'on peut pas encore parler
de suicides confirmés au bureau du
coroner on parle de suicide pour le
terme de suicides de prisonniers parce
que les enquêtes sont toujours en cours
d'investigation puis vous pas non plus
pointé du doigt les communautés parce
qu'évidemment ce rend compte que ça
affecte énormément de gens dans les
communautés met donc dans cette réunion
d'urgence l'oeil des représentants élus
du gouvernement de l'organisme régional
cas steve et de la régie de la santé du
nunavik plusieurs délégués qui se sont
présentés pour justement discuter avec
les communautés de devoir suivre
d'alternative de solutions pour
justement enrayer la crise mais ça ça
reste toujours très abstrait ouais on
veut du concret parce que c'est avec le
concret que les choses vont changer
il faut s'approcher de ces jeunes acquis
qui ont des idées noires et mettre du
soleil dans leur ville à faire rayonner
la vie c'est sûr que il ya des
programmes qui existent c'est difficile
de parler de programmes qui ont été
exclusivement mis en place pour contrer
le suicide généralement c'est sûr que
les programmes qui
kiev des activités artistiques qui
scientifique sporting ont amélioré les
causes qui sont sous-jacents aux us et
donc on parle de persévérance de trouver
les champs d'intérêt pour les jeunes
beaux dialogues y met des mots sur ses
émotions quand on dit justement parlé de
l'acceptabilité de la la souffrance la
viralité met un mot sur ce qu'on ressent
aussi nos jeunes puis donc des activités
des programmes peu qui sont mis en place
peuvent contribuer à briser l'isolément
lite et la criminalité et la violence et
donc aider toutes les causes disons ou
les bassins sous-jacent du suicide
mais est-ce que tant que les les inuit
dans ce cas là mais les autochtones ne
se sont pas réapproprier leur culture ne
sont pas envelopper par les gens qui les
entourent leur communauté et tout est ce
que vraiment on peut s'en sortir mais je
pense que ça vient ça doit venir des
communautés je pense que oui comme
madame odette le disais les les
institutions sont là mais de las il faut
que ça se fasse de manière individuelle
et que le et que ça vienne des
communautés forcément parce que si c'est
si ce n'est que des grands programmes
avec des grandes thématiques qui
finalement dont sait pas trop si les
retombées sont si positif que si
concluante ça si ça rejoint les gc c'est
faut que ce soit fait par des examens
qui ont des gens ayant d écrire c'est
pour répondre à ses besoins elle aussi
qui vivent dans les communautés qui sont
là au quotidien avec
qui peuvent les encadrer c'est ça il ya
diverses activités qui ont déjà été
mises en place en tout cas où vous
n'avez qu'une avait quand même couilles
par exemple ce côté de la commission
scolaire kativik
il ya le programme les jeux de l'amitié
c'est oui je sais pas ce que nous avons
entendu parler les frenchies king des
compétitions sportives qui sont
organisées par les professeurs
d'éducation physique donc pour favoriser
l'entrepreneuriat la clé l'activité
physique les les liens entre les autres
les gels il ya des programmes qui sont
aussi offerts dans les écoles par des
organismes partenaires donc je pense par
exemple à l'initiative circuit qui était
cirque unique circuit carriker oui c'est
exactement donc cédé à tenir qui sont
activement des professionnels du milieu
et qui look qui ont été notamment
instauré par le cirque du soleil par
leur programme cirque du monde qui
viennent en qui on était
disons créé pour les jeunes en situation
précaire des initiatives en en dans les
arts les sciences à ces conditions
d'exécution souvent des étudiants du
nunavik qui sont représentés à
l'exposition photos actuelles du québec
et qui seront qui sont souvent qu'elle
du succès pour les expo-sciences du
canada oui pas plus tard que en 2014 et
4 ans et c'est une jeune inuit de sa
louette qui a reçu quel tech a reçu deux
prix à l'expo-sciences du canada donc ça
donne de l'espoir puis ça motive aussi
les jeunes autour de donc de là à voir
des modèles et tout je pense que c'est
important aussi pour disons pour ce pour
motiver les les groupes de jeunes et
entre mais y'a pas que les jeunes aussi
en dialyse adultes ainsi si on prend en
main un jeune et qu'il rende dans un
foyer dans déjà leur logement surpeuplé
avec des gens qui ont des idées noires
là aussi le pauvre ir tombant alors dans
sa réalité absolument c'est sûr que là
on parle d' étudiants qui fréquentent la
commission scolaire par exemple les ce
qu'on me faisait remarquer justement
c'est que c'est pas nécessairement les
étudiants sont pas nécessairement dans
le bassin des jeunes les plus à risque
de se suicider on passe du temps ce sont
les plus à risque mais pas forcément les
étudiants souvent ça ce qu'on me faisait
remarquer c'est régulièrement des jeunes
qui ont quitté le réseau de l'éducation
donc qu'ils vont être plus porter donc
dons qui sont qui sont plus isolés donc
songer pas nécessairement en contact
avec ce type de programme d'accord
en quelques secondes deux belles
initiatives
si je dis bien son nom le monsieur zhu
jin ho oui j'imagine c'est vrai débat
belles choses avec moi je n'ai nous eh
oui le hockey était très présent mais y
aider aussi des jeunes familles nous est
là pour le bc qui est bien d'autres
sportifs donc oui 77 important et je
saïs coin dit je pense qu à manic vous
auriez la possibilité de faire une
entrevue exclusive avec la la seule
communauté au canada je pense qui a eu
son dernier suicide en 1998
equani cheap avec mega man oui et parce
qu'ils ont développé une approche
holistique où toutes les sphères de
l'individu sont constamment maintenu
soutenu stimuler que ce soit le culturel
identité la langue la santé mentale et
ainsi de suite donc moi je suis curieuse
à voir comment ça se fait que ça marche
son semi solide comme communion oui
absolument à ce que si les citations à
tout le monde là-bas la wii parce que
c'est vrai qu'on dit que plus on est
plus et communautés sont isolés plus est
sont à risque d'avoir évidemment
beaucoup de gens qui se suicident
oui il ya d'autres des activités charles
qui ont lieu je sais pas on n'est pas
rendu est jusqu'à avoir une expérience
aussi positif quelqu'un uchida et
consorts sont ceux qu'on s'en soit sorti
autant mais il existe aussi des
initiatives que vous avez relevé n'est
ce pas du côté des arts en tout cas pour
aider lui tout à fait en 2015
l'université des premières nations
d'origine en saskatchewan rapporté un
projet de recherche qui avait pour but
de démontrer que l'art avait des avc
bien féloche et chez les jeunes oui
en faisant de bons en faisant des
ateliers d'art dramatique ou d'arts
visuels puis c'est une possibilité pour
ces jeunes de s'exprimer comme jeu ça
devient salée breathed l isolement
ça cesse on sait que le facteur les
allemands un des facteurs du suisse un
type c'était tous des culture à la
maison différine tu travailles pas tu
t'es tu te poses sept dépôts stimuler à
quelque chose dont tu vas perdre
beaucoup d'intérêt
donc moi personnellement les allemands
étaient un des facteurs pour moi qui m'a
amené à ses pensées noires et des choses
de ne faire aucun bilan accablant
vraiment dit ça permet aussi ça permet
de nos jeunes aussi de pouvoir
s'exprimer parce que quelqu'un est
toujours sonné tout jeune on a besoin de
pouvoir s'exprimer de pouvoir faire des
choses donc l'art est vraiment un
c'est un langage temps langage
inconsciente et si on travaille avec ça
puis on le fait on fait justement donné
à soi donc ces jeunes là comme une forme
de thérapie par l'art on pourrait dire
donc c'est ce que je trouve ce que je
trouve vraiment fascinant d'un seul ce
que vous avez lu le livre manikanetish
justement non mais ça tombe bien moi je
les lui ai justement faut que je vous la
donne la france parce qu'elle est
magnifique je l'ait retenue je les
inscrits à un moment donné à la fin du
livre et l'asie l'humain est beau
lorsqu'il choisit la vie ouais c'est
tellement bien maintenant mais c'est ce
qui est fascinant fait justement la fin
de ce livre
lorsqu'elle là c'est une phrase c'est
justement ces sept professeurs qui
retourna à oicha tai chi qui veut monter
en spectacle de fin d'année cette pièce
de théâtre le site de corlay avec ses
étudiants qui au début sont un peu
frileux elle pote la trouvent place dans
cette cette caisse interne et pourtant
c'est se mettent à a tellement se donne
libre pour complètement les décors la
musique ça c'est le livre en question la
loi deuxième roman de naomi fontaine qui
est excellent oui absolument mais si
c'est fascinant justement l'un des tous
ces liens qui se créent et puis cette
manière d'extérioriser un peu ses
émotions millions - les liens d'amitié
qui nous intéresse dans cette dans la
mise en la mise en scène de la pièce où
le conseil a oui absolument c'était un
livre très fort d'ailleurs et je pense
qu elle y raconte un peu sa vie parce
qu'elle même est retourné travailler
enseigner aux jeunes de wash hâter leur
donner de l'espoir
est ce que vous l'avez lu michel ce
livre non mais j'ai pris ma tête j'avais
pour mon téléphone pour prendre la photo
là mais je vais le retrouver
c'est une fille que j'admire non même à
lire absolument c'est un livre très
inspirant alors charles dans l'est parce
qu'il ya quand même plusieurs projets
intéressants dans différentes
communautés dans les communautés dans
les commissions scolaires crie en un
projet qui est super intéressant qui
s'appelle mixed signal qui est un projet
d'arts multidisciplinaires c'est que le
projet consiste à inviter des artistes
canadiens autochtones et non autochtones
à venir faire des ddd formation
intensive de création donc ça permet aux
jeunes de les garder sur les bancs
d'école parce qu'il vient faire ça dans
les commissions scolaires dans toutes
les commissions scolaires crie donc son
sens c'est vraiment un projet qui kiss
qui s'accentue sur la création sur le
développement d'un projet donc il ya un
petit peu d'entrepreneuriat au travers
de tout ça donc les gens qui désirent
s'exprimer ont la chance de le faire et
l'on voit au loin des projets de la cdc
des jeunes qui font des vidéos le pays
chantent à des musiques d'aujourd'hui
c'est c'est merveilleux c'est vraiment
des projets extraordinaires
c'est un projet qui est et qui était qui
est élaboré depuis 2015 quand même et
puis donc voilà il ya aussi un autre
projet qui s'appelle tapiskwan qui est
un collectif qui est un don qui est
devenu un organisme qui est un kit à
puisqu elle en fait c'est un organiste
qui tapissent coincé sur un organisme
qui donne un lieu des changes
je veux m'en excuser moi qui donne un
qui favorise les champs de la culture
indiqué m libre et du design par le
biais de dollar en fait son travail sont
sur le côté entrepreneurial aussi donc
née il ya un accompagnement qui se fait
dans cet organisme et on le voi avec les
images qu'on voyait se réapproprier
aussi son patrimoine d'exactement son
identité attaque en tant que première
nation on a besoin de se réapproprier
ces des densités le canton mais tant
qu'on s'envoie la ville on n'a pas accès
à cette assez à ces ressources là elle
est dans le boa les avoir notre
grand-mère de la fable donc on a besoin
de pouvoir fabriquer exemple des paniers
des corses on ne sait pas comment
comment je pouvais me ce que je dois
apprendre ça faire des raquettes ou ce
que je peux apprendre ça faire des
requêtes qui peut me montrer
c'est des choses que des choses comme ça
puisqu'on qui peuvent organiser des
activités comme ça pour pour partager la
qualité en face il ya camille qatar qui
est acquitté d'un centre d'artistes
hamas teillage kiki qui prend aussi les
échanges qui donne des lieux des lieux
d'échangés entre artistes et les jeunes
où les artistes peuvent se rendre là
aussi pour pouvoir échanger sur des
idées sur des concepts sur des sons sur
plaine willy qu'ils peuvent avoir en
commun oui oui à travers les lectures
que j'ai fait on parlait d'auto
gouvernance auto gouvernance comme une
une porte de sortie aussi vers quitter
l'a7 environnement sombre et se dire on
se prend en main on se gouverne et on se
réapproprie sa culture tout ça ça
revient toujours à la même chose
michel qu'est ce que vous en pensez auto
gouvernants se dire ok on se prend en
main et on organise notre vie on se
réapproprie notre culture encore là on
revient toujours à la même chose la
réappropriation de la culture et donc de
son identité
c'est extrêmement important il faut
passer par là et le canada doit
seulement accepté je dois parler pour
ici au québec accepté que pour nous
c'est une des voix je vais parler en mon
nom personnel où j'ai entendu depuis
plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs années et
bien avant l enquête nationale où des
femmes va avoir vécu une discrimination
ou une violence au sein même de la
communauté ou une attention parle
d'autonomie gouvernementale ou d'auto
gouvernance et que nos communautés ont
pas encore fait ce processus de guérison
et d'accepter les rôles de tous et
toutes ont les chacun sait on veut aller
là mais pas n'importe quelles conditions
quelles seraient ces conditions là mais
dans la guérison c'est de faire en sorte
que les femmes puissent retrouver les
droits qu'on qu'elles ont perdus à cause
d'une loi la loi sur les indiens
d'accord on applique cette loi là en
pensant que tout est indien toutes les
portes et 1 600 et 1 6 2 à part ça c'est
pas nous c'est d inonder anishnabe des
êtres camec est situé alors ce faut se
le réapproprier dans l'identité
culturelle dans l'estimé de soi dans les
barmen et
des choses comme ça là qu'il faut
considérer c'est un exemple oui
tellement de choses
il faudrait pratiquement faire table
rase effacée et tout recrue profil bas
sur est dans l'enseignement spirituel
ok spirituel mais l'ouverture d'esprit
on s'entend le qu'impose pas juste une
façon de faire l'homme et la femme
un belle place dans cette spirituel et
spiritualité la dent comment faisait on
fait les choses aujourd'hui qu'on va
voir marié avec d'autres nations
je sais que c'est faisable
parce que c'est ça fait partie de ma
guérison aujourd'hui puis de ma fierté
je sais que c'est faisable mais c'est
pour les femmes ou les personnes qui ont
eu des pensées noires justement
retourner en territoire ou d'apprendre à
chanter au tambour qui était pas
nécessairement et nous mais qu'on ne le
droit avec tambour contient la main on
les voit fier et fort que les parois ou
cinéma bis nous les les danseuses à
clochettes et on a plein de jeudi nous
qui danse sont belles
ça c'est des exemples ce sont des gens
les parois en verre vraiment cdc le
contact spirituel la spiritualité
gagnant viole un côté au travail de tout
ce qui peut aider vraiment aussi à la
spiritualité autochtone moi j'ai pu la
suivre en jeunes n'ont pas même
entraîner dans ce quelque chose de très
plaisant à découvrir il ya des bonnes
idées bon enseignement dans ce kit c'est
les parois battu danse danse ta vie tu
te qu'en tant qu'artiste en tant
qu'artisans tant qu'artiste de ta nation
béton l'artha joue si ta culture puis tu
travailles sur toi même en faisant ça
donc c'est vraiment magnifique
on parle aussi du père l'âge c'est le
perlage des artistes qui font juste et
danseurs qui font le peuple leur
porteraient galice et c'est un travail
minutieux qui font puis qu'ils font à
tout les jours et puis ça laisse aux
vous une façon aussi et il ya aussi la
réappropriation de sa langue
mechelle odette votre votre mère entre
autres par le in ou avec vos enfants à
vous
sais pas si vous vous le parler ce que
vous parlez elle tue peu beaucoup ou pas
du tout tél
c'est cute à la maison j'avais avec une
très bonne amie qui vient de personnes
et donc je la prends un peu à la pisam
yolo la junte mais très patiente simon
professeur qu'elle accepte mes erreurs
et on corrige ou amant singles et bons
mots le faire vite qu'il est entré dans
la vie dont je vois toutes sortes de
beaux accents donc c'est quelque chose
qui était un vide chez moi qui sera
appelée tranquillement ça fait du bien
oui mes enfants trouvent que je parle
plus que d'autres des fois il se gratte
la tête pourquoi c'est pas juste
il faut écouter faut pas voir pas ce qui
était mon cas j'ai toujours eu peur de
parler ma langue
oui est ce que eux le parle pas du nom
mais qu'on fait un peu très très peu
est ce qu'il le comprenne très peu aussi
très fort c'est bien que les gens autour
leur belle maman du côté de papables oui
ça m'est aussi donc rien je pense
qu'elle parle et nous aussi aux enfants
puis ça pour moi c'est un bon ben ça me
fais aurait avoué absolument est
absolument
alors il ya cet événement-là qui se
déroule à montréal très prochainement
est ce que vous y participez d'alors a
d'ailleurs à dialogue pour la vie 2018
cette conférence prévention suicide avec
le thème favoriser une vie d'espoir avec
et pour nos enfants et nos jeunes est ce
que vous êtes impliqué là-dedans michel
non on m'a sollicité par campo faire
soit la conférence d'ouverture ou d'être
parmi ceux et celles qui pourraient
parler de la vie et on est exposé d'être
en audience à victoria donc je devais
refuser toute invitation alors je vais
suivre ça avec une chandelle à la maison
et pour ceux et celles qui nous écoutent
faut penser aussi à ceux qui sont restés
derrière suite à un suicide
la mère le père les frères et ça
le regard que mon père ma famille ma
mère et mes enfants
une fois que je me suis réveillé là ça
va toujours être le petit regret depuis
je leur demande pardon
donc fois envoyé beaucoup de lumière
beaucoup d'amour avec ce pour ceux qui
restent en arrière puis dans nos
stratégies dans nos réflexions dans nos
recommandations faut penser à toutes ces
personnes là qui ont qui ont besoin de
guérison aussi qu'ils ont besoin d'amour
puis de soutien voilà merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir accepté de témoigner ce
n'est pas facile c'est un exercice
d'humilité très difficile merci et puis
bonne chance pour la suite de votre vie
n'est-ce pas merci merci merci la vie en
effet merci à charles ix banque
laurentienne encore une fois et mathis
harvey merci beaucoup mathis d'avoir été
avec nous au cours des dernières
semaines
je pense que ellis revient la semaine
prochaine on espère que l'aigle
exactement merci à vous d'avoir assisté
à ce facebook live et puis on vous
attend donc vendredi prochain à 12h15
pour un autre rendez vous salue
[Musique]